adèle continues to be one of the most relatable famous people out there the singers the latest relatable moment her credit card apparently got declined the star who Forbes claims will earn more than 80 million dollars this year is said to have shared the embarrassing story with her fans at her sold-out show in San Jose over the weekend Adele reportedly told the crowd quote I went to H&M and my card got declined oh my days pretty embarrassing nobody knew it was me but I was mortified the 28 year old has apparently been doing a lot of shopping while in the States she supposedly confessed to going a little crazy at Target to quote they have everything literally I spent $100 on stuff I do not need I never need anything i buy at Target but it's amazing